[Music]
it was the last friday of the school
year and i had been actually subbing for
a teacher for three days
it just seemed like a nice day
on may 18 2018 a gunman entered a high
school in santa fe texas and opened fire
i looked down and i realized in my pants
i had bloody holes in my pants and i
realized
i'm
shocked the gunman killed 10 people
flo rice was shot six times and then
finally
scott managed to um
he managed to find me
for four years flo and scott have told
their story over and over to push for
new laws that could prevent mass
shootings it's made them part of a
recurring conversation on guns in the
u.s and a cycle the country has seemed
stuck in for decades a mass shooting a
push for reform
and then no action the tragic school
shooting in santa fe texas this time in
el paso nine people killed and dated how
many years did we have to go through
this congress is parallel we
collectively seem to ask the same
question what does it take to pass some
gun reform in this country but here's
the thing this cycle of inaction on gun
laws isn't exactly accurate
over the past few decades federal
legislation on guns has been rare
but in state legislatures mass shootings
have led to new gun laws
thousands of them
and how those laws have emerged can tell
us a lot about the future of guns in the
u.s
in 2020 a study tried to determine the
impact of mass shootings on gun policy
they looked at 25 years of high-profile
mass shootings then they looked at gun
legislation passed during that time over
3 000 laws across all 50 states when
they took a closer look at those laws a
pattern emerged that at first seemed
unsurprising state legislatures
controlled by democrats were more likely
to pass tighter gun laws
republican-controlled states typically
loosened gun laws
but they found a key difference
mass shootings didn't have any
statistically significant effect on the
number of laws passed by democrats while
for republican legislatures a mass
shooting roughly doubles the number of
laws enacted that loosen gun
restrictions in the next year
to
arm more teachers for example or arm
more school staff that's james baragon a
politics reporter at the texas tribune
there is more access to guns afterwards
a state like texas would go more towards
pro-gun policies in the aftermath of a
gun shooting
texas has some of the loosest gun laws
in the nation and that matters for
people all over the country
people probably don't know about the
importance of
state gun laws and really state laws in
general our gun laws at the federal
level had been frozen in time since
basically the 1990s
which allowed the states to have a much
bigger role in a much bigger influence
in how gun culture played out in their
jurisdictions
let's look at texas
in 1991 a gunman killed 23 people at a
looby's restaurant in killing texas
a woman there named susannah hupp lost
both her parents in the shooting she
believed she could have stopped the
massacre and turned her experience into
a crusade for loosening gun laws i'm mad
at my legislators for legislating me out
of the right to protect myself and my
family
it worked in 1994 texas elected a new
governor george w bush who made it legal
to carry a concealed gun his first year
in office and set off a trend in the
state that's continued for decades
for example in 2012 after the sandy hook
elementary school shooting drew
attention to gun laws across the country
texas responded a few months later by
creating a program allowing some school
employees to carry guns in school
in 2017 a gunman killed 26 people at
first baptist church in sutherland
springs within two years texas made it
legal to carry weapons in places of
worship
but after the santa fe high school
shooting governor greg abbott did
something unusual
he asked lawmakers to consider a red
flag law which would allow authorities
to take firearms away from a person
courts deemed dangerous
that is not something that republicans
in this state often do flo and scott
were also pushing for legislation in
response to santa fe like laws that
would hold parents accountable if their
guns were used by their children to harm
people they also pushed to make it
harder to buy ammunition online our
shooter he just checked the box and said
yes i'm 18 and they delivered it to his
doorstep
you can't get alcohol delivered without
showing proof of id or something but he
ordered ammunition
their hope for stricter laws was in line
with texas public opinion polling showed
only a small minority of texans
supported loosening gun laws and just
over half supported tightening them we
thought it was common sense
that
this would be done they came to flo's
hospital room the week of the shooting
and we had the governor lieutenant
governor we had congressmen we had
senators
their wives there's chief of staff all
in her room at one time at least 20
people
and said we're going to take care of you
we promise
we'll be there for you we'll fix this
but in the end these proposals along
with abbott's openness to red flag laws
went nowhere after gun rights supporters
went after him the gun culture is strong
but the gun lobby itself also exerts a
lot of pressure on texas politicians
there were bills that were put out there
but they never made it out of committee
later in 2019 two shootings in west
texas just weeks apart prompted
lieutenant governor dan patrick to
suggest another tighter gun policy
closing background check loopholes that
is a very strong comment from a
lieutenant governor who is very pro-guns
who is very friendly with the nra but
republican leaders were saying we may
have problems here democrats are pushing
to take over the state house for the
first time since 2003. after elections
were over with republicans still in
control in 2021 texas passed
constitutional carry
there would no longer be a requirement
for texans to have a license or receive
any training to openly carry handguns
for me it's very scary because if i see
someone in public with a gun i will
panic
going to send me into an anxiety attack
that constitutional carry law that the
state legislature passed in 2021 had
been rejected by republican leaders but
as
the republican party has gone further
and further to the right on issues you
get a fringe of the party that is much
more vocal about
all kinds of issues including gun rights
in recent years a better organized gun
control movement has seen more success
with tightening laws in some states but
the movement to expand gun access isn't
stopping
in 2002 fewer than half of the 50 states
had one party in control of both the
state legislature and the governor's
office
today three quarters of the states do
that means in the places where
republicans or democrats have full
control they can push through new gun
laws with little chance of a veto
so what happens
and you see it in state house to state
house is one state passes a law that is
very successful for one side of the
aisle and then another state house
adopts a very very similar law remember
that constitutional carry law in texas
today 24 states have similar laws on the
books for that too and more than 400
local governments across 20 states have
adopted variations on a second amendment
sanctuary law meaning a city town or
county refuses to recognize any state or
federal gun laws that they believe
violate the second amendment these
things get replicated they get cloned
they go from state to state and they
essentially make up this patchwork of
laws throughout the country
in june 2022 in the aftermath of the
uvalde shooting in texas president biden
signed the most significant federal gun
bill in 30 years
one thing it does is incentivize states
to pass red flag laws
but it can't make them do it
that power still belongs to the states
i have survivors guilt because i'm alive
and so i feel like it
i have to keep speaking out i have to do
what i can there's times when
i just think i'm gonna stop i i cannot
do this for my own mental health but we
just keep we keep going
[Music]
you